welcome back I'm very upset two of my
favorite thing sandwiches and meat
they're coming under attack did you hear
environmentalists are pushing for
attacks on meat claiming hamburger
steaks and other delicious delectables
are harmful to the environment and then
there are the sandwich police you know
them
some scientists claim that they're bad
for the planet too for all kinds of
reasons because of ingredients and
packaging so data can you believe this
ridiculousness no I also saw that
there's gonna be mandatory Roof Gardens
in Denver yeah no you can do it you
should go to waters mandatory mandatory
roast Gardens and then that's
meaningless I think that
environmentalists should take a page out
of the Donald Trump playbook and try to
figure out a way to make the art of the
deal there are a lot of conservatives
that you it's a surprising number to me
that support the idea of a carbon tax
and if they were to do that then all of
these other little things that they want
to do that would hurt the things people
are trying to sell for people to eat
would go away all right Greg what do you
make of this I mean you're carnivores I
am and I'm gonna I'm gonna break this
story I sent her out to you guys no
response about how selling or giving
away straws at restaurants can you can
go to jail did you guys just so you know
about some evolutionary science here are
gonna meet made us the king of all
beasts because there's no other way to
get protein rich nutrients than meat you
could say all eat spinach you're gonna
have to rent a u-haul to eat all the
spinach that you get from mistake it's a
fact the reason why we have these brains
is because we eat so much meat for
200,000 years so if you think about PETA
and environmentalist groups veganism
they're all able to exist now in 2018
because of the meat eaters of the past
who built this amazing civilization that
allows unfocused adults to chase their
fringe causes okay so I don't get this
it's so crazy Jesse so they're saying
that this causes global warming all of
it I mean it's it's um
to me what about the children Jessie
sandwiches gonna do for the kids don't
touch the Lunchables right Americans
will tolerate crazy left-wing
environmental wackos to a certain extent
when they tell us we can't use the
aerosol deodorant we say fine when they
say we have to put the bottles in a
different bin recycle say ok say ok but
you know what then they come after the
meat and they come up now
no we're drawing the headline at the
hamburgers and the hotdogs they've
already talked about we can't drive
certain cars we don't like that they've
also said something about sodas I think
they don't like drinking big sculpts so
does any more here right nothing
so it's gotten to the point where it's
become too ridiculous and they're just
clowning themselves I had two hot dogs
today no bond well I didn't have any no
I didn't have any edible buns there was
nothing to do with a knife and fork or
Regis I cut it up and used a little
spicy mustard oh my god pepperoni I also
had pepperoni today - it's good - you
know what you're gonna be doing this in
10 years when you're my age pal no more
bread you're gonna be eating nothing but
meat yeah what's wrong with bread its
carbohydrates sugar make you fat
there's no that I'm not so sure about
that no you might one more thing Greg
I'm just saying what happened then over
the hall in New York they don't need
bread they put toxins in their head all
right one what do you have to say about
this
you know what surprise your folks you
know what well let me just before I get
to that Kimberly let me just say what
surprised me the most was they say the
worst sandwich the one that has the
worst most impact on the environment is
a breakfast sandwich with sausage bacon
eggs yeah they said it's the equivalent
of driving 12 miles if you just eat one
well I drove all over the country this
morning would you go for a bacon egg and
cheese over like a sausage egg and
cheese I prefer the bacon egg and cheese
yeah sauce is just a nice little lean
patty on there I'll take this yeah this
is worse than your private plane now
either in terms of good but if you want
bread on those sandwiches what you're
eating is ten times
better than breakfast cereals granolas
yogurt a big dishes yogurt a big juicy
yogurt from Chobani or wherever is like
have an ice cream for breakfast yeah but
if you have if you have lean meat if
your protein an egg yellow the yolk not
white enough of this egg white i'm with
yolk is the most important thing though
I prove you by the way it's tasty it's
beautiful I was stunned to realize it
says that Americans eat 2 times as much
meat as anybody else in the world that's
because we win all the world wars 1 we
gotta go we're undefeated